have to hack through this door it's
gonna take me a little while to do it
though all right guys let's hold off
three waves of enemies again destiny so
destiny is a first-person shooter MMO
type game this game was so anticipated
it blew everyone's minds everyone for a
year at least was like yeah it was like
the hugest launch ever or some [ __ ] like
that again with this kind of day one
sales tells me that there are two kinds
of people in the world very disappointed
people and people in denial no one's
really satisfied that first of all the
gameplay the gameplay is really solid
it's tight the controls are awesome this
is how a console first-person shooter
should feel ever play a first-person
shooter and you're like I could really
go for a keyboard and mouse right now I
swear to god I can't pull off these head
jobs this game plays really good you
feel like a badass pulling off headshots
it's not the impossible feat it usually
is on a console it has MMO qualities
where you know you get different armor
and that armor buff certain moves that
you have and you level up that armor and
it can do more [ __ ] and you get certain
guns and certain guns do the same thing
and you kind of gravitate towards
certain types of guns because you have
certain kinds of gameplay different
people play differently which is all
very cool and playing with your friends
is a lot of fun I mean you link up with
your friends you're going through and
you're just kicking ass and short that's
fun and a first-person shooter with your
friends should be fun so you're having
fun and that's all fun another great
thing is how the game looks I was just
walking around on the moon I was like
holy [ __ ] level design this is awesome
look at the Milky Way the earth was kind
of eclipse like a crescent earth and
then we were going about our mission and
I looked up again the earth was full and
I was like the earth it's all rotating
that's red you feel like you're in a
different world you feel like you're on
a different planet when you're on a
different planet and the music's great
the music's really excited I feel like I
would want to get the soundtrack to this
game if it came with the game not going
to go out of my way to buy it but if it
came with the game yeah there'd be ought
to be a great addition be like a nice
little apology from them like yeah sorry
there's no plot to the game here's the
soundtrack though but then there are
things that just don't really gel in the
game first of all it is cool that you
can pick between three classes what
these three classes really essentially
don't really matter they do a portion
some of the you know you throw a grenade
the grenades will be different they're
melee will be different they're special
will be different other than that
they're pretty interchangeable in the
end you
just using the same guns so you'd shoot
the same way it's the same kind of game
I'm playing as a warlock and a hunter
I'm going to be shooting guys the same
it doesn't matter that way and that you
take a step back you're like well it's
an MMO but it's not it doesn't have the
variety of an MMO it's not like I have
28 different moves it's not like Diablo
or the witch doctor plays differently
than the wizard the wizard plays
differently than the barbarian imagine
witch doctor wizard and barbarian and
they all use a gun and shoot guys this
same guns - same moves it's the same
thing and the story what is I don't know
the game starts out so awesome loses
cutscene and guys are on Mars and it
shows this travelers this big spherical
thing on Mars you're like holy [ __ ] and
you'd hear this big backstory about how
this thing just shot mankind through
progress it was this age of wonder and
then we colonize different planets and
everything was awesome and in the same
cut saying they're like and well then we
lost all of it and this evil came and
found us now we have one human city left
so in the backstory civilization rose
then fell and now we're fighting this
game probably would have benefitted from
having us play the part where
civilization is falling because evil is
coming and we're losing cities
sequentially we start feeling that loss
so we know what we're fighting for this
one I'm just going I'm like why am i
killing these guys yeah they're big and
bad and they're evil and all that [ __ ]
but why is it happening this little
thing that looks like the thing from
Tron assault laughs now remember that
thing that comes his voice by Peter
Dinklage he's like I've been searching
for you for a long time you've been dead
for quite some time alright follow me
we're gonna go to war you're like did
you just raise me you raised me from the
dead you just said you did how long have
I been dead Who am I doesn't matter can
you resurrect everybody who's ever night
I don't know because the game doesn't
tell me all I know is that I was raised
from the dead now I'm fighting a war you
don't know who the bad guys are other
than the fact that they're bad because
the sphere is good so now these guys are
bad and I just showed up and it took
everything while we're on the subject
what is the traveler is it like the cube
from transformers you know where it came
from but it causes you know hope and
life and all that good [ __ ] is it
sentient is it the Borg did we create it
was it created by humans is it from the
future is it from the past
is it a spherical version of the same
traveler that took Wesley Crusher and
Star Trek The Next Generation I don't
know I suppose it's about as plausible
as anything else because you just kind
of have to jump to your own conclusions
and your own motivations because the
game doesn't tell you because there is
no story this little ghost thing might
as well just race you've been like I
searching for you for a long time I
raise you from the dead all right now
let's go farm for gear because that's
what we're going to do that's really the
point of the game is where the fun is
that you just farm for gear there is
kind of a story there's there's deeper
explanation of what's going on in
certain things in the game and the form
of these little grimoires that you find
but don't get too excited you can't read
them in game you have to go to
bungie.net create an account link your
account then you can read them on there
share them and get why can't I read them
in the game that is so [ __ ] obnoxious
that you have to do it's about as
obnoxious as follow the link below to
WWE John Strom to find out how obnoxious
it actually is that's all I'm gonna say
about that do you feel like you missed
out on something I know it's dumb and so
much in this game is rinse and repeat
9/10 times there's a conflict in this
game it happens like this little Peter
Dinklage voice guys like have to hack
through this door it's gonna take me a
little while to do with them you're like
all right guys let's hold off three
waves of enemies cuz that's going to be
the situation that's the raid that's the
things really irritating Bungie was like
after level 20 it's a different game
entirely well in the sense that you need
to now farm for gear by doing missions
you've probably already done before that
consists of hey I got to get this door
open give me a second alright hold off
three waves of guys if that's different
that yet I guess but it's not different
not different at all this game does have
merit like I said it's fun to play it is
fun to play with your friends for sure
but it's not groundbreaking there is
ZERO story to the game which you feel
the loss of that more because the game
starts out in its intro with a really
awesome description as to the universe
that you live in is through the solar
system you experience none of it and you
just rinse and repeat your missions that
consists of holding off three waves of
guys that are pretty much the same among
three different planets four different
planets three planets in a moon and at
this point in the game I'm at the point
where I'm now going to play the game to
farm for gear in missions that I've
already done so I can farm for more gear
and just do the mission again that I've
already done a hundred times I'm not
supposed to get there so early in the
game like Diablo 3 after after 2.0 patch
came out Reaper of souls and [ __ ] I was
on that forever before I got bored for
farming gears I want a farm for gear I
can do it for free and Marvel heroes so
in a world where a game has fun gameplay
but a disappointing lot of other [ __ ]
that's not really revolutionary I will
say I had fun playing destiny but in the
end destiny is worth buying at sale
price if this game cost half as much as
it does now I'd say yeah sure but you'll
have a good
five dollars worth of fun out of it but
buying it right now no you're gonna burn
through that in no time they're gonna be
like all right next
now what want to play The Last of Us
again let's do that
so destiny have you played it what did
you think about are you one of the
people who were like no I'm still having
fun with the game and it's still a blast
and this is awesome
or were you disappointed with the game
you're like that's it that's what we got
[ __ ]
whatever your take comment below let me
know and as always if you liked what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more